so the the transition from going to a
com from uh
a stand-up to uh you know into hollywood
man
how has that transition started you
always picture yourself like doing
voiceovers and uh and acting and
things of that nature um i think in the
beginning
it was one of those you're
pre-programmed as a as a comic
you're pre-programmed for certain goals
for example every comic back in the day
always wanted to have the
tonight show episode they wanted to have
the hbo special
not a netflix special because there was
no netflix not showtime or anything they
wanted the hbo special and then they
wanted the sitcom
once they got to the sitcom level then
they could build a fan base from that
that everybody you know so when they go
on the road they could sell tickets that
was always the pre-programmed goal you
got to do this to do this do this
and then once you're done with tv then
you could try to make that transition to
film
so everything was looked at as a
stepping stone with stand-up being the
first step
yeah so like with with me uh
i love being on stage that was my number
one love uh my manager
i took on a manager because they got a
lot of work you gotta love it
you gotta love it they gotta pull you
off yeah
you know but okay all right all right
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna ask you
this question mike
but you know there comes a time like
even you as an athlete when you're
boxing
where you do this you've been doing you
know that's for so long
that it's almost like you start to hate
it or you love it so much that you hate
it
you know what i'm saying do you lose do
you lose love out of something
comedy and boxing boxing i understand it
comes a certain time that you can't do
it
at the level that you really want to do
it and that's the top level
this acting game is immortal it keeps
you living forever
imagine you know you know what it's like
to have a week on broadway or something
like that a big
theater or something you can't imagine
anything better if you're one of those
guys that like attention and like
seeing yourself on television and you
know and i don't know and i'd be saying
wow i don't even like guys like that but
that's the kind of guy i
am um you'd be surprised when i say
somebody put a camera in my face
you know he'd be surprised it's just a
drug
i'm i'm [ __ ] up i'm sorry i grew up in
the 90s i know what you said on camera
uh you put a camera you know what i've
always wanted to know when you put a
camera in my face and i would say
anything there is no shame i don't know
why i'm like that i hate being there
that's the part
oh my god you put a camera in my
face i just turned to somebody i don't
even know
i always used to wonder like what is he
what he that's what he's saying on
camera i wonder what he says to the
fighters in the ring
when you're when you're hitting these
guys you know i'm sure you're not just
quiet like
oh you know pow pow no you gotta be
talking about oh god yes
i'm a pig you ever tell anybody you know
like
as soon as i beat you i'm gonna go to
sizzler or something something just
just basic you know it's really nasty
stuff it's stupid [ __ ]
i'm a nut
you